- Sure, we wanna go to
all the touristy things,
but we can't look like tourists.
I gotta pack in outfits, you know?
What if we get invited to some VIP event?
You think we'll go on a
picnic while we're there?
- I like that shirt
but you always complain
that you look like a carpenter in it.
- I'm nervous, you know
I have a fear of flying.
- Chris, do you wanna hold my hand?
- My travel lotion and
my travel deodorant,
and my travel razor...
Where's my Purell?
- Oh, I have Purell.
- No, my travel Purell.
Purell?
- Yeah.
Do you have any Purell?
- I need some more Purell.
- If you keep taking selfies
we're not gonna get to
the airport on time.
Delete that.
I look awful.
Chris, you've got to roll everything
if you want it all to fit.
- Should I bring a second suitcase
in case we go shopping?
- Chris, you're $4,000 in debt.
But I mean, if we see
something you have to have!
- We have to get a tie,
we're on vacation.
- Okay, one tie.
One tie.
- Oh my God, what if we, like,
both fall in love while we're there.
What if we just moved into that apartment,
like, found some wives.
- Rich wives.
Look at how fat he is!
- I told you I want a pug.
I don't think I have enough room
for a blow dryer.
- Chris, be heavier.
At least this is proof you're not fat.
Right?
- That's the nicest thing
you could have said to me.
It's usually freezing there.
- Well, everywhere is freezing.
I said that you aren't fat.
- I know, you said it,
but you made me think about it.
(sighs)
I think I'm just in a
sensitive place right now.
- Oh my God, this place is perfect.
- Airplanes make me feel gross,
I need to take a shower
and do my hair immediately.
- [Keith] There are so many pillows.
- I'm gonna bring both of these.
- Chris!